Yeah,
yeah,
it's definitely a growing trend.
Um,
there's always been a connection between
philosophy and science.
In fact,
in the beginning there was no
distinction,
so aristotle was a philosopher.
He was also a biologist.
He was also an economist,
um,
and in a way he was a physicist,
so yeah,
but it is coming closer together again.
And I think the reason for this is that,
um,
you know,
scientists are studying things of great
interest to philosophers like,
uh,
the scientific study of free will that
really got going.
I'm not until the 19 eighties when these
Liberte experiments that I talked about
started up,
um,
there's been a lot of good social
psychological work on things like
weakness of will and self deception for
well more than decades.
Um,
and I've been interested in that stuff
since I was young.
Um,
it is growing I think.
Yeah,
because there's more scientific done a
work done now on these philosophical
topics.
Um.
Oh,
I don't know what else it might be that
people are thinking.
Well,
traditional philosophical methodologies
have been around for a long time and
they've gotten us to a certain place and
that's good,
but we can get even further faster by
bringing more on board,
you know,
scientific results.
Um,
and,
uh,
I actually do a lot of work with
scientists.
In fact,
I think I can mention this now.
I'm,
I'm about to receive a four point
$8,000,000 grant to start a freewill
project at Florida State University
where I am.
And,
uh,
the granting agency is the John
Templeton Foundation.
Now,
most of the money will go out in grants
to scientists and others who make
proposals on free will a two point 8
million that's going to go out to the
science of freewill.
And what I'd like to see happen is that
we have teams of neuroscientists,
social psychologists and philosophers
working together,
uh,
to design a freewill studies and then,
you know,
write up the papers,
analyze the results and so on.
Um,
so for me this is a really exciting
time,
uh,
at the intersection of science and
philosophy and,
uh,
this thing called experimental
philosophy,
which didn't really exist until 10 years
ago has really taken off.
I was up here in New York City last
Monday,
um,
to be in a session on experimental
philosophy.
There was a big audience,
a lot of excitement.
Uh,
so in 10 years it's gone from nothing to
something pretty exciting.